- [Kelly] I love your outfit.
- (laughs) Thank you.
- Like honestly, I was
getting ready for the show
and you were rehearsing
and stuff, and I was like,
we were all talking
about your whole style.
Are you really into style?
- Yeah, I'm really into fashion.
I've been like shifting
more towards it just lately,
you know, just trying to change my--
- Yeah, well, you do it well.
- Yeah, thank you, thank you.
- Well, meet Kal, he likes
naans and sweet pickles.
So yeah--
- Naans and sweet pickles.
Absolutely.
- Do you have any like major
obsessions that you love
that you can't live without?
- Probably, I've been trying
to go like vegan lately--
- Oh, nice.
- Oh, good for you.
But I've been craving steak, but I--
(Kal and audience laughs)
- Oh, exactly, or cheese.
- Yeah, yeah.
Actually--
- It's so good for you though.
Yeah, but I made a mistake, I
ate a piece of bacon yesterday
and I just didn't miss the--
- Okay, wait.
- Did it kill your stomach?
- Yeah--
- How do you accidentally
eat a piece of bacon?
- Okay, I'ma tell you that,
it's actually a funny story
'cause, okay, so I was really hungry.
I told the hotel to
bring me an egg sandwich.
So when the egg sandwich got
to my room, it had bacon on it.
But if I removed it,
then the whole sandwich would fall apart
and I was really hungry--
- [Kelly] Yeah, you lean in.
- And, I just ate, I just ate it.
I was like it wouldn't hurt.
- Yeah, oh, I love bacon.
- It didn't hurt.
- So wait, where are you from originally?
- I'm from Alabama.
- Oh, a Southern boy.
Oh, that's gotta be real
hard to give up meat.
'Cause that's all we all grew up on, okay.
Have you spent any time in Alabama?
I've toured there quite a bit.
- Yeah, Alabama and Mississippi,
and Huntsville, Alabama,
where I went to space camp as a kid.
There's a big NASA thing down there.
- When you said Huntsville,
like I always think prison.
I don't know for some
reason, so I was like,
what were you doing there?
- Well, I went to the
NASA part of the prison.
- You went to space camp,
that's so cool, okay.
- [Kal] Oh, whoa.
- [Kelly] I love this.
- Whoa, so quick. You guys are so quick.
I didn't know you had that.
- We are amazing, this team.
We're Emmy-winning.
I don't know if you know, Kal.
(audience applauding)
So I have to ask, this is crazy
because I feel like they're deadly,
but I feel like you had a
pet baboon at some point.
Like, is that real?
- Yeah, but--
Can't they kill you?
- Wait, you had what?
I feel like they can definitely kill you.
- Yeah, I found that out
like two weeks later.
(Kelly laughing)
I didn't know it was a baboon.
- What?
Wait, what did you think it was?
- I thought it was just
a baby monkey, like...
- Where did you get it, and how did,
did it attack you?
- No, I adopted it from this guy
and I had it like for two weeks and then,
I was posting him on my social media
and then I read a comment
that said, that's a baboon.
I was like...
(audience laughing)
Then I was like,
she can't know what she's talking about.
So I Googled it, and I'm looking at this,
I'm holding him, I'm
looking at the picture,
and I'm looking at him, I'm, like,
"It's really a baboon,
you know what I'm saying."
- Oh my gosh.
So, first of all, congratulations,
I love that your first song is with Drake,
like (mimics disco siren), that's amazing.
(audience cheering)
So, you worked with Drake?
- My first, my first--
- Not your first thing, your
first mainstream, yes, yes.
I should've said that, your
first mainstream thing.
But I love that, you worked with Drake
and also John Legend, who I love.
I mean, he's so much fun
to sing with and work with.
He's so cool and so talented.
But I heard that there was a story of you
missing a FaceTime from Drake.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
When he first did the record,
he like FaceTimed me at like the next day
at three in the morning and I was asleep.
- [Kelly] Well, of course
you are, so is the world.
- (laughing) Yeah, so I
woke up in the morning,
I was like, "Oh, I missed
a FaceTime from Drake."
Like I was panicking.
I was like, "What if he
didn't do the song now,
you know what I'm saying?"
So I had waited the next
day, that same time at three,
I stayed up all the way
to three in the morning
and FaceTimed him around the same time
and he answered.
- Oh my God.
- Was he like in a different time zone?
Is that why?
- Yeah, he was in Canada.
So I don't know the time difference.
- Well, that's not that
big of a time difference.
I'm like, oh my gosh.
I don't know if I've
ever been that person.
That's like rocking it at 3:00 or 4:00 AM.
That seems like a
difficult lifestyle for me.
So wait, you're playing,
your song's "Beautiful Lies"
love that title by the way.
And "You're Mines Still" first
day, so what are they about?
- "Beautiful Lies" is
basically about a love triangle
with someone just, you know,
leading you on, you know.
It's about love, someone leading you on,
telling you beautiful lies,
things you may believe.
And "You're Mines Still" is just,
you know, "You're Mines Still"
it's just toxic,
just a toxic--
- [Kelly] I love it. (laughs)
- One of those toxic--
(audience applauding)
- I love it, I love it.